[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeig euch heute
mein video wie ihr mit ein paar tipps
und tricks sehr stark vereinfachte
hinter rouladen herstellen können die
sehen einfach super aufwendig aus sind
aber gar nicht so aufwendig und ich habe
das ganze noch mit kurs profitiert wir
benötigen drei rouladen vom rind meine
sind ziemlich großes ding werde ich sie
gleich auch noch halt ihren und der
metzger der hat sie auch schon platt
geklopft
außerdem benötigen wir noch soll vom öl
ca 2 esslöffel wasser
drei esslöffel senf habe ich ihn mit
strafen genommen
seit verfahren gemüse früher rund um die
rouladen nachher machte befüllen habe
ich hier verschiedenes gemüse ich habe
zum beispiel paprika außerdem möhren
lauch zwiebeln ihr könnt aber auch
champignons nehmen oder alles was nicht
in den sinn kommt die roulade wird jetzt
mit salz und pfeffer gehört anschließend
gebe ich da noch ein esslöffel senf
drauf und verstreichen
[Musik]
dann kommt das gemüse meiner wahl am
ende der roulade und wird dann zum
anderen ende hin aufgerollt
und beim eine roulade ist sehr lange
papier noch einmal in der mitte und die
endstücke pickt sich anschließend noch
mit einem zahnstocher genauso bereite
ich auch die anderen fall rouladen vor
[Musik]
die zahnstocher dienen dazu dass die
rouladen nicht aufgehen dem topf werden
sie aber vor dem servieren auf jeden
fall raus nehmen
in meinem topklasse ich dann das öl heiß
werden und gäbe anschließend meine 6 uhr
laden die meinen und braten sie von
allen seiten scharf an
[Musik]
das ganze mache ich auch bei höchster
temperatur also immer wieder wenden dass
ich auch nichts anbrennt wenn dann alle
seiten schön knusprig braun gebraten
sind könnt ihr schon ein teil des
wassers zu erleben
das wasser sollte in afrika zwei
zentimeter hoch stehen also nicht ganz
bedecken und wenn ihr dann merkt dass
das wasser langsam mit weniger vierter
könnt ihr auch immer wieder mit dem nach
schenkeln jetzt muss nur noch der deckel
drauf gegeben werden ich lasse ihn gerne
einen spalt offen und das ganze mit ein
und sechs stunden vor sich hin garen und
dann sind die rouladen auch schon fertig
das im topf zurückgebliebene was war das
schlimmste wirklich sehr lecker jetzt
kommt nämlich die gemüsebrühe von vorhin
noch mit hinein
außerdem zum antiken noch etwas mehl mit
wasser vermischt und dann lasse ich das
einmal aufkochen und die soße ist schon
fertig für den couscous benötigen wir
eine große fein gehackte zwiebel 400
gramm entstand kurz kurz 400 gramm
wasser 2 knoblauchzehen 1 teelöffel salz
für die farbe ein teelöffel kurkuma und
zwei esslöffel butter
zuerst wird die mutter in den topf
schmelzen und nimmt am besten nicht die
allerhöchste temperatur der butter
heimweg sehr schnell anbrennen
dann wie die zwiebel für ein bis zwei
minuten darin gebraten
jetzt presse ich noch die zwei
knoblauchzehen hinein wartet das ganze
für eine weitere minute an
und dann gebe ich auch schon dass dafür
eine
nun können auch salz und kurkuma mit dem
zugegeben werden wird das einmal schön
verrührt und komplett aufgekauft jetzt
wird der kurzfilm zugegeben den herd
einmal komplett ausschalten und den
deckel darüber geben
nach nur fünf minuten wird der
kopfschutz ganz schön aufgelegt hat und
damit sie auch bevor wir bereit
[Musik]
am schönsten ist meiner meinung nach
auch wenn ihr dann die rouladen auf dem
kurs kolleg dann könnt ihr das ganze
noch mit der üblich gebliebenen soße
begießen in der mitte habe ich auch noch
eine schale mit sofort noch einmal etwas
möchte und dann ist das gericht auch
schon fertig weiß jetzt auch hunger
haupt auf leckere rinderroulade mit
couscous im orientalisch angehauchten
teil da macht das gerne lacht ich freue
mich über jeden kommentar über euer
feedback und sagt wir zunächst mal auf
welches kitchen
[Musik]